how old is too old to watch cartoons
interesting I
detest cartoons I've never watched The
Simpsons I never watched Family Guy I
see you being like let's get and just
watch no I'm not that high energy I'm
like let's get high and watch like a
nature documentary or something it's not
really I don't like Adult Swim I I don't
think there's a too old but they're you
know those like edgy cartoons there is
like some weird like adult person who
gets like stuck into that do you know
what I'm saying and then they're wearing
like a weird hat like with ears on it
like there's a girl that I'm seeing
vividly
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that
kind of gets a little creepy too yeah I
don't watch like
Bob's Burgers or something that even
that I go all right grow up you know so
I don't know I think there's just like
like 13 I don't know that's a crazy
answer probably but
I hate cartoons